là par exemple demain on part faire un
tournage pour une grande marque de
téléphone pas du tout ce trésor tout va
bien nous donner sept conseils pour pas
stressé avant un tournage juste après un
troc à la valette 10 secondes d'un trop
long pour 1
[Musique]
et salue les gens derrière l'écran c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique moi
encore je suis extrêmement heureux de
vous retrouver une nouvelle fois pour
cette vidéo harry si vous êtes nouveau
sur cette chaîne
on parle de vidéos de matériel de
caméras de montage tout ça donc si c'est
quelque chose qui vous plaît n'hésitez
pas à cliquer sur le petit bouton
s'abonner la cloche tout ça parce que
cette chaîne va très probablement vous
intéresser alors quand on part en
tournage qu'on soit professionnel ou
amateur il ya toujours une petite dose
de stress qui vient mettre son grain de
sel dans notre petite mécanique l'aïe
qui potentiellement peut nous amener à
faire des erreurs ou a raté des trucs un
tout simplement le stress dans un
tournage c'est un facteur complètement
déterminant il y en a que ça booste et
un axe art ferme complètement
bref c'est quelque chose à prendre en
compte et rassurez vous on va pas faire
des exercices de yoga quoique mais
plutôt tout un tas d'astuces avant et
pendant le tournage qui vont vous
permettre de shooter beaucoup plus sur
ses astuces elles sont au nombre de sept
et on va commencer par des petites
choses avant de tourner premièrement ne
proposait jamais à quelqu'un quelque
chose que vous n'avez jamais fait alors
je dis pas qu'il faut jamais essayer de
nouvelles choses bien au contraire
mais quand vous partez en tournage que
ce soit pour un client ou pour un autre
projet un petit peu important c'est
quand même pas idéal de ne jamais avoir
essayé ce que vous allez faire ce jour
là parce qu'on peut facilement dire oui
mais bon j'ai déjà vu faire ou jeu c'est
grosso modo comment on fait donc je
risque d'y arriver
ça c'est un coup à vous mettre une
pression de malade et éventuellement
même avoue foire et le jour du tournage
donc clairement il faut au moins avant
de s'engager sur un tournage s'être
entraînés à faire ce pour quoi vous
allez être payés ou ce pourquoi on nous
a demandé de venir deuxième conseil il
faut absolument que vous preniez le
temps de faire un bris posé avec la
personne qui vous a commandé une vidéo
parce que moi ça m'est arrivé souvent et
vous ça vous arrivera aussi sûrement
souvent qu'on vous dise non non mais
vas-y ta carte blanche
tu peux y aller il n'y a pas de souci
fais comme tu le sens que ça c'est un
petit peu la pire des choses qui puisse
vous arriver en termes de brief parce
que vous savez pas vraiment ce que la
personne en tête elle c'est parce que
vous vous avez en tête
donc ça peut partir dans tous les sens
et surtout ça va vous empêcher de vous
préparer correctement à ce tournage là
parce que vous savez pas où vous allez
vous savez pas où vous mettez les pieds
donc prenez le temps même si la personne
dit nan mais c'est bon dit lui on se
prend une petite heure on discute
tu me dis ce que tu vois sur le projet
tu me dis comment veux tu imagines les
choses moi je vais t'expliquer aussi
comment j'imagine les choses et comme ça
on sera tous
on saura où on va ça mange pas de pain
et ça prend pas beaucoup de temps
troisième conseil qui en découle c'est
préparer votre tournage et mettre au
clair vos idées en gros après le brief
il va falloir que vous passiez par une
phase de création d'écriture ou de
storyboards si vous êtes à l'aise avec
ça pour essayer de visualiser
concrètement à quoi va ressembler votre
vidéo idéalement avant de partir shooter
vous devriez avoir en tête grosso modo à
quoi va ressembler cette vidéo qu'est ce
qu'il va y avoir les dix premières
secondes qu'est-ce qu'il va y avoir par
la suite s'il va y avoir des interviews
que la vidéo soit en forme dans votre
tête en fait que vous l'ayez déjà
visualisé comme ça vous saurez où met
l'accent pendant le tournage vous saurez
quels sont les points essentiels à ne
pas rater et vous pouvez vous faire un
petit listing de plan a ajouté également
quatrième conseil et là on se rapproche
du moment un petit peu fatidique où le
tournage va bientôt démarrer
c'est de préparer votre matériel la
veille alors préparer son matériel la
veille c'est vraiment pas du luxe cinq
ans c'est possible ça va vous permettre
notamment à un moment où vous n'avez pas
de contraintes de temps particulière de
vraiment vérifier si les batteries sont
chargées si les cartes sd sont formatés
sans avoir le speed de se dire merde que
je prenne mon train info frais de ma
bagnole il faut que j'y aille il faut
que j'y aille il faut que j'y aille
travail aussi vous permettre de détecter
d'éventuels soucis techniques que vous
pourrez corriger sans être dans le speed
et en angoisse complète parce que votre
carte sd elles fonctionnent plus parce
que la batterie s'est déchargée parce
que voilà et bien sûr on fera une petite
vérification rapide le lendemain juste
avant de partir histoire de checker que
tout va bien qu'on n'a rien oublié et ça
vous laisse la nuit aussi pour penser à
la tient mince j'ai oubliés tels
objectifs j'ai oublié mon stabilisateur
j'ai oublié le micro voilà vous avez
tout le temps pour y penser pour ajouter
des trucs syli a besoin et du coup on
parle beaucoup plus serein sur la presta
tranquille où on sait qu'on a tout bien
que le matin elle marche et tout ça et
tout ça tout va bien nous sommes donc le
jour du tournage ou un jour ou deux
avant et le 5ème conseil c'est tout
simplement d'arriver en avance si on
vous dit arrivée à 16 heures soyez là
vers 15 heures comme ça ça vous laisse
le temps d'observer un petit peu comment
et la lumière comment sont les locaux
les endroits où vous allez devoir
shooter faire déjà des petits plans
d'installation sans que les gens soient
là si c'est un événement par exemple et
idéalement si vous avez pu faire du
repérage là
veille ou quelques jours avant pour ne
serait-ce qu avoir une idée des lieux et
ne pas être surpris ou devant le fait
accompli
au moment où vous arrivez c'est encore
mieux ça évitera par exemple d'être
surpris si les conditions de lumière
sont toutes pourries et de prévoir la
veille d'amener un éclairage d'appoint
par exemple si j'aime conseil et là on
est dans le coeur de l'action on est
pendant le tournage penser tout
simplement à respirer et je vous avais
dit qu'on ferait peut-être un petit peu
de yoga dans l'histoire non ça on vous
le dit souvent mais la respiration c'est
hyper important et souvent quand on est
concentrés moi je sais que j'ai tendance
à retenir mon souffle beaucoup quand je
prends mes plans et c'est donc penser à
respirer à prendre le temps et si vous
sentez que le stress arrive pendant la
prestation qui a des imprévus ou qui a
des choses que vous maîtrisez pas prenez
toujours le temps de respirer pour vous
calmer si vous êtes stressé si vous êtes
sur les nerfs si vous êtes énervé votre
travail va s'en ressentir
et forcément ça sera moins bien ça sera
moins agréable donc pensé voilà à faire
ce petit travail de respiration de temps
en temps pour être sûr que tout va bien
voilà tout va bien se passer et enfin on
arrive au septième et dernier conseil
c'est tout simplement de laisser de la
place à l'imprévu
si vous avez suivi tous les conseils que
je vous ai dit avant vous allez arriver
avec une idée très précise de ce que
vous voulez quelque chose de très cadrée
et bien dans l'événementiel il ya
toujours des choses qui se passent pas
comme prévu donc n'hésitez pas à sortir
du cadre
le fait d'avoir le cadre ne vous oblige
pas à rester dedans mais s'il se passe
quelque chose de super sympa que vous
aviez pas scriptés que vous n'aviez pas
prévu faut pas s'interdire de laisser un
petit peu de place à tout ça quand on
fait de l'after movie quand on fait du
mariage quand on fait de l'événementiel
il ya toujours des choses qui sont pas
prévues il faut essayer d'anticiper au
maximum et surtout d'être prêt pour ce
qu'on n'a pas anticipé justement et
voilà les amis j'espère que vous êtes
beaucoup moins stressé à l'idée de
partir shooter et que cette vidéo vous
aura aidé un petit peu il vous aura
donné quelques trucs pour vos prochains
tournages d'ailleurs si vous l'avez
trouvé où kim si cette vidéo vous a plu
vous pouvez bien entendu vous fendre
d'un petit coup de blaster sur le pouce
en l'air qui se situe juste en dessous
de cette vidéo si vous n'êtes pas encore
abonné da c'est le moment d'aller
cliquer sur le petit bouton juste en
dessous et d'activer la cloche pour être
notifiée dans les commentaires vous
pouvez également mettre vos conseils
d'avant tournage ou deux pendant un
tournage pour être moins stressé ou nous
mettre tout simplement
votre expérience vos expériences de
tournage je suis sûr que ça pourra aider
beaucoup de monde donc n'hésitez pas à
partager tout ça dans les commentaires
et en attendant moi je vous dis rester
curieux les amis et à très bientôt pour
une prochaine vidéo
bon alors pour toi qui reste jusqu'à la
fin toujours et je te remercie j'essaye
de tenir une par semaine une vidéo par
semaine là le bullois recommencer mais
genre de ouf je m'accroche
vraiment je m'accroche et mais moi un
petit commentaire d'encouragement dans
les dents les commentaires parce que je
sens que dans les semaines à venir ça va
être très compliqué d'en sortir une par
semaine
j'ai plein de choses que je vous
racontais donc j'ai envie quand même
j'ai envie